[Musik]
wolfgang bosbach wir hatten oder sie
hatten gestern schon mal kurz die
hochzeit ihrer tochter angesprochen
jetzt war er gebrauchen der
kanzleramtsminister heute bei uns im
gespräch heute früh und sagt
familienfeiern im sommer und im
spätsommer stellen sich man nicht darauf
ein dass das funktioniert was haben sie
bisher beziehungsweise was hat ihrer
tochter nach dem gestrigen tag mit der
hochzeit gemacht dass die schon
abgeblasen
ja die haben wir heute leider absagen
müssen da sind natürlich viele tränen
getroffen geschlossen wir sind ja zum
zweiten mal betroffen thema luftfahrt
eine mittlere tochter nathalie war oder
ist ja noch bei germanwings beschäftigt
da stehen 1400 arbeitsplätze auf dem
spiel
und da geht es übrigens nicht nur ums
geldverdienen meine tochter ist mit
großer begeisterung in der luft gewesen
für germanwings also wenn der staat sich
engagieren würde wäre es schon schön
wenn er das auch tun würde mit dem ziel
möglichst viele arbeitsplätze zu
erhalten
und da denke ich nicht nur alleine an
meine tochter sondern auch an die 1399
kollegen die noch bei germanwings sind
und die keine ahnung haben wie es
weitergeht da ist natürlich der raum
köln/bonn auch mein ehemaliger wahlkreis
in besonderer weise betroffen
also erstmal nur die tochter nummer zwei
getröstet heute müsse über die tochter
über drei trösten weil die hochzeit ins
wasser fällt im moment sind beide so
enttäuscht dass sie sich auch nicht
irgendeinen neuen termin bemühen weil
sie sagen papa denken sie ans restaurant
denken sie an die an die band die
bestellt worden ist die wollen alle
wissen wie geht es denn weiter muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen wir wissen es nicht
wie die lage im juli august september
sein was also erst mal ist alles
abgeblasen mann freut sieht man
verschickt einladungen hatten
hochzeitskleid gekauft land steht man da
mit leeren händen aber der bräutigam
bleibt wohl bei der stange
das wort sagen unsere große hoffnung und
unser mitgefühl
gilt ihnen und ihrer familie ihrer
tochter und vor allen dingen unsere
hoffnung dass das eben natürlich nur
verschoben ist und natürlich nicht
aufgehoben was macht wie konnten sie den
trost spenden
das kann man nur indem man sagt denn das
ist im grunde kein trost aber es ist die
wahrheit es gibt menschen die viel viel
härter betroffen und getroffen sind zb
weil sie in ihrer familien freundes und
bekanntenkreis patientinnen und
patienten haben die mit dem leben ringen
dass es viele gibt die um ihre
wirtschaftliche existenz fürchten und
dass es doch gut ist dass man eine große
familie und keine existenzielle not hat
eine hochzeit ist natürlich ein
besonderes erlebnis in den meisten
fällen ja nur einmal im leben und
erfreut man sich drauf da bereitet man
sich monatelang vor das heißt das was
ich jetzt gesagt aber ist kein echter
trost aber ich glaube in ein zwei wochen
sieht die welt wieder anders aus gerade
wenn man das mal vergleicht mit schweren
schicksalsschlägen die andere menschen
in dieser zeit erleiden müssen
[Musik]